first of all I'm so glad you're here
plugging a book because a lot of people
I mean
a lot of people did have you in the dead
pool yeah
maybe you yeah I you know I had a
horrible accident about seven years ago
um I was given a two percent chance to
survive the night that didn't tell me
that obviously because I wasn't really
there but they told my family and uh I
was put on a thing called an ECMO
machine which you having read the book
you would know what that is but it's a
it's no I did I took notes I underlined
it oh no I believe you
um but they call that a Hail Mary that's
what they do when they put you on an
actual machine when it's a Hail Mary and
five people were on ECMO that night and
the other four died and I somehow made
it well um what God is a fan yeah I mean
I know your feeling about that
um
well I know I'm a fan maybe I'm okay I
know that uh once you've referred to it
as a force and you know it I believe I
believe that I believe that a higher
path there is a higher power right I
believe a very close relationship with
him that's helped me a lot and
somebody's on your side yeah
um
everybody's on your side everybody's
glad you're here yeah and I must say the
human body reading that book and I did
it's amazing to me
the Paradox the the it's so fragile to
human and also so resilient it's it's so
easy to die and also it's kind of hard
but you approved
hard to die it can be yeah you tried
yeah no yeah I never I never tried but I
did so many drugs at certain times that
I knew that it could kill me but I would
do it but I never I never wanted to die
but the real thing for me and the
troubles that I've had is that reality
is an acquired taste that's what I
believe that's a great life
I have had a great deal of time a great
deal of problems acquiring it right and
uh it wasn't until
I became I I became really safe I felt
really safe in my sobriety and really
strong in my sobriety and to tell you
the truth I am resilient and I am strong
oh my God and you look healthy you look
healthy it's amazing
no I feel very lucky that I'm someone
who could do drugs and still does drugs
you don't have any on you do you
know
and it doesn't affect me that way but I
mean your stats I mean unbelievable 6
000 AAA meetings took 55 Vicodins a day
this is like Joe Dimaggio with the 56
game hitting streak I mean no one's
going to come up with these stats no
one's going to beat you on some of this
stuff yeah and some of the things that I
went through to get that many pills a
day oh you know my whole life was math I
mean you know the story about the open
house can we talk about this sure yeah
this is a because I remember the David
Bowie song like waiting for the man
right it's where it was a teenager first
learn the concept of what addiction was
I think from that song like this is this
big rock star but he's waiting for the
man yeah Keith Richards just said this
in doesn't matter how big you are how
famous you are the drug dealer you are
his [ __ ] yeah you're waiting for the
man but you didn't wait for the man you
went to open houses and stole drugs from
people's medicine cabinets such a better
plan right
I would I would look in the paper and
look at open houses on Sundays and I
would go and I would go upstairs to The
Medicine Room and if it was an elderly
couple I knew I'd hit it home
[Applause]
[Laughter]
look at the dates you know and if the
dates are old and there's still a lot of
pills you can take a lot of them and
then and I'm telling it's a horror story
and I'm telling it in kind of a funny
way but as I drove off I was like
nobody's gonna say chandler just stole
drugs out of my medicine Garden
exactly